wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
nico ich weiß dass papa nicht immer
einfach ist nein das warst du dich du
machst immer was du willst
kein problem pepe unser toller sohn hat
eine eigene firma in deutschland und
verdient viel geld du weißt es nicht und
möchtest du hier auch eine eigene firma
gründen
ich kann mir helfen ich kann mich
unterstützen nein danke nico ich habe
respekt vor deiner entscheidung aber ich
glaube das funktioniert so nicht warum
nicht ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
du es ohne hilfe von mormonen papa
schaffen kannst und ich mache mir auch
sorgen
mir ist egal was du denkst und ich
glaube auch nicht dass du dir sorgen
hast doch nicht nein du bist einfach nur
seine ruhe haben nein ich will dass ihr
nicht mehr streitet ich habe mir etwas
überlegt ich bleibe hier wie lange ein
paar tage ja wochen vielleicht länger
ich helfe dir
ich weiß nicht ich überlege mir
nico willst du hin warum